you orders of a problem and Luigi here
and today can another video for you guys
however this is not going to be centered
round fall at four I do have some
gameplay of some pretty good ethical I I
just going crazy and let me get free
damage on it so enjoy that but this will
be more about my channel and stuff like
news and updates so first things I want
to say is I did change my name to mad
Luigi ma d lu ipi that is just my core
gamer tag and I decided I shouldn't have
anything else than that keep it simple
mad Luigi so that's my new met gamertag
it's my new youtube name and also it's
my name on twitch you guys don't know I
have a twitch channel I haven't really
done much with it however i will be
starting to live stream as of putting
this video out so if you're watching
this video go check out my stream since
i'm streaming fall for right now i will
be streaming 8 p.m. to 11pm tuesday
thursday and sunday that is pacific
standard time I know it's pretty late
for you guys in the east coast I will be
saying that all of my time subject to
change I just trying things out right
now getting into the grind of twitch so
yeah check it out it's twitch.tv / mad
luigi be sure to check it out if you're
interested in watching me live stream
and follow it if you want to see any
time i go lie that will be in the
description and as you guys told as you
guys heard i said twitch TV / mad luigi
madl uig i go check out meet live stream
if you want to now i hope you guys had a
really good thanksgiving i haven't
posted many videos in the past like week
because i was out of town for
thanksgiving so hope you guys have
enjoyed that i enjoyed mine i hope is
all good and swaging yada yada i do want
to say a big thank you to everyone who
come out and supported me since fall for
has come out I've gotten a lot of videos
out and I've gotten a lot of good
feedback on those videos views watches
those are the same thing shares likes
favorites all that subscribers and I
appreciate all of you doing that i
really do it's it means a lot for you to
help grow my channel since it means that
i'm doing something that people like so
yeah that's kind of basically the video
change my name twitch TV / mad luigi
have a good thanksgiving hope you had to
get thanksgiving and thank you very much
for everything you guys have done for me
so yeah that's about it and i'll catch
you all in the next fall out for video
or next video bye make which is probably
gonna be falling for but maybe it's not
all right guys pset